muchos debate y pocos acuerdos en la
última cumbre de los 27 en bruselas el
punto más difícil de consensuar fue el
de los precios de la energía que ha
alcanzado récords en el continente en
medio de un intenso invierno españa o
francia bien que europa tome más medidas
conjuntas ya que la comisión ha tomado
para sí ha aceptado una de las
propuestas del gobierno de españa que es
la compra centralizada de gas y por
tanto también el poder tener una reserva
estratégica de gas en europa creo que es
una buena noticia pero es insuficiente
donde sí hubo acuerdo fue la postura
conjunta hacia la pretensión de rusia de
invadir ucrania boleta vino touch que no
quede ninguna duda que si rusia se mueve
en contra de ucrania la unión estaría en
condiciones de imponer sanciones que
podrían derivar en un costo enorme
extract en más cost
en cuanto al kobe 19 francia y alemania-
se expresaron en contra de las
restricciones impuestas por italia a
turistas provenientes del bloque minute
y cesc no planeamos en poner pruebas
dentro de la unión europea porque
estamos comprometidos con el correcto
funcionamiento de nuestro espacio común
del mundo nos resta sco no sobre la
vacunación los líderes acordaron la
implementación de dosis de refuerzo y
para ello solicitó de manera conjunta
nuevas dosis del fármaco elaborado por
modernas